Hogwarts Legacy has officially confirmed
the name house and a brief background on
four of our professors we have Abraham
Ronan our charms professor of Slytherin
house
Shall We Begin
welcome to unified of chant Mirabelle
garlic a Charming Hufflepuff who will be
our herbology professor oh hello class
please welcome the newest Rose in our
garden Dinah heckett our Ravenclaw
defense against the dark arts Professor
the best way to practice
by doing start with YouTube and ease up
sharp the grizzled former Aura who will
be our potions master and is also a
Slytherin Solutions is one of the most
challenging and hazardous subjects
taught at this school don't worry my
fellow gryffindors I'm sure our day will
come soon enough
I think the rollout and backstory on
these professors has been absolutely
brilliant to be honest first off if you
think back to the original book series
obviously a huge part of its success was
due to the characters but it wasn't just
Harry Ron and Hermione that we fell in
love with it was the entire cast of
Hogwarts professors like Dumbledore
McGonagall Hagrid and for some people
even Snape way back when I first started
making Hogwarts Legacy videos what seems
like so long ago I made a video where I
said this in order for Hogwarts Legacy
to have a strong original story that
steeped in Wizarding lore they'll need
strong supporting characters the
original series had a huge cast of
strong supporting characters that became
just as beloved as Harry Potter himself
in some cases even more so than Harry so
back to the present now that we're
starting to learn more about these
professors it's really starting to feel
like a whole new era of Hogwarts with
characters that have the potential
keyword potential there to be as
memorable as some of our longtime
favorites which I know just sounds crazy
to say but think about over the course
of this game over the many hours however
many hours it's going to be of this
action RPG we're going to be getting to
know these professors and while playing
a video game is certainly a different
feel than reading a book what we've
learned so far about these professors
really has me excited to learn more
let's start with ESOP sharp who will no
doubt have fans drawing comparisons to
one Severus Snape this is a guy who is
clearly going to push his students and
he does not care about being your friend
or being liked he's a guy who's
battle-hardened from his time as an aura
now originally some fans thought he
could possibly be Phineas nigellous
black due to his resemblance to Gary
Oldman in his portrayal of Sirius Black
we eventually learned that isn't the
case and we also learned that he is in
Slytherin house and here's what his
character card reads the gruff and
keenly astute Professor sharp enjoyed a
lengthy and successful career as an aura
until an injury forced him from the
field not wanting to push parchment
around a desk at the ministry sharp
decided his time would be better spent
sharing his extensive experience
involving battle-worthy drafts and
elixirs with the students said Hogwarts
not easily impressed and wholly
unwilling to suffer fools he takes
genuine pride in students who excel in
his class despite his challenging
curriculum of course as I mentioned the
character card also confirms he is in
Slytherin which was a bit of surprise to
some who were expecting a Gryffindor
Professor to be revealed when he
considered that the first three
Professor cards we saw were from the
other three Hogwarts houses ravenclaws
you know what I'm saying here now if
you're worried that he's just a little
too similar to Severus Snape Community
manager Chandler Woods says not to worry
he tweeted out sharp may feel some
familiar potions Professor tropes
Slytherin tough curriculum Long Hair Etc
but he definitely has certain qualities
all his own that bring a unique flavor
to his character personally I actually
think this is a super smart tactic to
have these professors that draw
comparisons to some of our old favorites
I mean they were iconic characters for a
reason guys in fact I would even say
that this is intentional not to make him
an exact copy of Snape but for people to
at least get a similar feel some
resemblance certain traits that are
almost fallbacks touchstones if you will
to characters that we all know and love
from Harry Potter's day now whereas
sharp certainly won't be a professor
that you'll want to hang around between
classes the exact opposite can be said
for the delightful Mirabelle garlic our
herbology professor from house
Hufflepuff look I mean her Sunny
demeanor was evident from her very first
appearance in that original trailer and
it's further backed up with her
character card description london-born
Professor garlic grew up in a household
full of Muggles and didn't really feel
at home until she was a student at
Hogwarts in fact she will tell you that
it was at the famed School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry she finally blossomed
herself and discovered her extraordinary
affinity for Magical plants her Sunny
demeanor and Flowery language Charmed
colleagues and students alike prompting
some students to worry she may one day
leave them for another Greenhouse but
Mirabelle garlic would never leave her
students so even if the right witch were
to come along she'd simply have to love
Hogwarts as much as Mirabelle does now
the fact that she's muggle-born could
set up a very inter interesting
relationship with one Phineas nigellous
black if he is indeed our Headmaster as
many are expecting black of course held
to the views of Salazar Slytherin that
magic should only be taught to magical
families up next we have our charms
Professor Abraham Ronan and something
just tells me that after playing the
game he's highly likely to be a fan
favorite like garlic he seems to have a
fun-loving personality I mean his card
even mentions how much he values
friendship with his students jovial and
lighthearted with a Perpetual twinkle in
his eye Professor Ronan considers his
students friendships and extracurricular
activities to be just as important as
the subject of charms itself in response
to having been tutored by a rather
austere father before and during his
years at Hogwarts he developed a passion
for games of all forms particularly
gobstones he allegedly met his wife
during an especially Lively gobstones
tournament to the Delight of most of his
students his unorthodox teaching style
often incorporates gameplay we've
actually seen a bit of that gameplay in
the trailer here like sharp Ronin is
also in Slytherin house so who do you
guys think will be the head of Slytherin
house let me know in the comments below
one of the other character cards
revealed was that of our defense against
the dark arts Professor Diana heckett of
house Ravenclaw like sharp she also
worked for the ministry of magic but
spent time in the department of
mysteries so rather than being an aura
it sounds like she was unspeakable for
the ministry of magic and after reading
her character card I'm getting some
mad-eye Moody Vibes here take a listen
to this the stern but likable Professor
heckett takes her teaching
responsibilities quite seriously after a
successful career with the ministry of
magic during which she is rumored to
have spent time in the department
Mysteries she retired to become
hogwarts's defense against the dark arts
Professor though she is happy to be in
Hogwarts some believe her Hands-On
teaching method satiates an innate
desire for action of all the professors
we've seen so far it certainly seems
like these were the four featured the
most prominently and the four who will
likely have the biggest impact on our
journey in the story aside from of
course Professor Ellie Azar Vig even
though big hasn't had his own character
card just yet we already know quite a
bit about him Chandler Woods Playstation
blog post from back in March of 2022
said the following about fig to unearth
Mysteries behind ancient magic and stop
randrock's Rebellion you'll need a
friend and mentor to guide you along the
way enter Professor Eleazar fig whose
investigations into rumors of a goblin
Rebellion have earned him an uneasy
skepticism from the ministry of magic
alright now I'm not gonna predict that
we go to the ministry of magic in this
game look it'd be incredible if we did
but it certainly seems like even if we
do not the ministry of magic is going to
feature prominently in this game I mean
we have two confirmed professors here
who previously spent time working for
the ministry then we have fig here who
is basically under the watchful eye of
the ministry and has a skepticism toward
him then we also have this other angle
that game director Alan 2 dropped in the
recent gameplay showcase when he
mentioned that the field guide we
receive in game is actually sent To Us
by the ministry of magic so this whole
angle with the ministry of magic is
definitely something to keep an eye on
leading up to the game and then of
course once we get the game in our hands
and are able to play it as well in terms
of Fig's house and subject we still
don't know many have speculated ancient
runes for his subject but
Transfiguration is also a possibility as
well muggle studies maybe arithmacy I
feel like those are less likely my money
is still on Ancient runes as being the
most likely one but we'll just have to
wait and see now obviously we still need
a Gryffindor Professor somewhere in
there because after all each house needs
a head of house which actually now that
I think about it is there like a
prerequisite at Hogwarts or some rule
left by the founders that there must be
at least one staff member from each
house at all times I think there would
have to be right so possible candidates
for the Gryffindor Professor include the
aforementioned Professor fig the mother
of natsai onai who's been confirmed as
our divination professor and the yet to
be confirmed but highly speculated
Professor Weasley who also has a good
chance at being the deputy head mistress
McGonagall Vibes anybody anybody so as
for all the professors who have received
highlights by the marketing team at
Avalanche so far we have Abraham Ronan
Dina heckett Mirabelle garlic and now
ESOP sharp and when they first started
revealing these character cards I was a
little concerned we'd be getting too
many story details but I think they've
honestly done a brilliant job with the
reveals on these and I'm left wondering
will we see any more we also have seen
character card profiles for the
following students Nats ionai poppy
Sweeting Sebastian sallow and Amit the
car and while Amit got a card just like
the others there's a chance his
character could have a very different
role to play in the game and he may not
be a True Companion like the other three
actually I break that all down in
another video which you can check out on
the right side of your screen now there
you can learn more about our Ravenclaw
companion as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon